das erste video wo ich mal böse
kommentare vorgelesen habe so gut
angekommen jetzt habe ich mir gedacht
ich mache ein zweites freut euch immer
habe ich alle namen zensiert die man
einfach ganz normal bei den youtube
kanal finden kann außerdem nahmen die
halt über google+ kreiert sind da kann
man ähnlich hätten und blau und mit der
begrüßung
ich habe versucht das wird nur ihren und
mit zusammen verreisen aber du willst du
dumm da wo du oasch kong kraft da ja ja
es ruckelt ha ha du bist einfach nur zu
schlecht also gewisser herr der nicht
mal ein vernünftiges profilbild hab ich
bin nicht zu schlecht ich bin unfassbar
gut in allen möglichen spielen da könnt
ihr sagen was ihr wollt und da verstehe
ich auch nicht wenn man dann so
vor einiger zeit hat sich im urlaub war
dieses bild über instagram gepostet und
darunter war dieser kommentar das
kinderspielzeug hatte ich als kleinkind
und das ist gay am sorry das ist halt
mein telefon brode muss kendo wenn du
mit anderen und komm lass uns eine
geschichte erzählen jeder nur ein satz
ich fange dann mal an es war einmal ein
conny der fitte sein kleines pony das
pony bekam und danach wurde es bill
gates später kamen chuck norris und
wollte kann nun hieß es marvin dieses
pony sprang von einer klippe auf luca
mit einer geilen sex stellung wurde luca
vergewaltigt luca bekam das ist ein was
ich wie kommt man auf so einen scheiß
was ist das denn allein das letztere
kommentare von der gleichen person
geschrieben wurden
ich habe stets sich wie kann denn eine
geschichte so ausarten allein schon es
fängt an
es war einmal ein conny der fitte sein
kleines pony was ich habe extra keine
namen zensiert weil ich finde sowas
nicht schlimm ich find's einfach nur
mega krank wie kampf hat sich so was
ausdenken um mal wieder zurück zum thema
worum es eigentlich geht
daumen runter habe ich den daumen hoch
gegeben war eine tolle aussage
11freunde unter dem unter einem letzten
video wo ich das gemacht hatte mit
dieser albtraum sache mit witzbold
meinte nicht so voll viele darunter
folge cloud von ape krachte es doch
extra ich glaube dass da extra von dem
ich hab das sogar in dem video gesagt
ich müsste jetzt so machen wie bei age 3
mit dem witzbold also das recht leute
darunter schreiben das ist echt
unfassbar man man man
typisch coni typisch coni auf der suche
nach der lösung
okay ganz ruhig barrel
die auch mal wieder einen kommentar der
einfach die kreativität von hater
bekräftigt
sucht ihr eigene sachen du [ __ ] [ __ ]
ist besser als du anus [ __ ] also was
soll ich zu so etwas sagen alter das ist
ja das geht nicht darauf ein das ist ja
meine lieben freunde die folge heute war
ein bisschen kürzer weil ich dachte die
letzte folge war ein bisschen länger
deswegen werden wir das ganze mit einem
kommentar von ig hundefutter
ich nehme das ganze als kompliment das
ist jetzt nichts worüber man sich dann
irgendwie will ich ihm freudig hoffe es
hat euch gefallen wenn ihr davon
eventuell mehr bedeutet das böse
kommentare lesen zwei wenn die eventuell
3 point oder vier dann schreibt böse
kommentare neben nimmt euch ganz normal
ich möchte sich dass die leute die sonst
meine zuschauer sind unbedingt ins video
kommen extra böse kommentare schreiben
schreibt einfach noch mal gute
kommentare böse kommentare nämlich immer
noch von ganz älteren videos soll dann
würde ich sagen würde ich mich freuen
wenn ihr euer leben genießt die arme
fällt die tut mir leid er irgendwann ist
sie kaputt